[Music]
we are all domestic
are all
the terrorists
[Applause]
welcome back
Godzilla I saw a clip of Japanese people
calling you Godzilla that must have
hyped you up
that was one of the greatest experiences
of my life
that honestly
everyone's like oh man welcome back like
and I I want to say it's good to be back
but that's a lie
so do you want to live in Japan I want
to I want to pull a PewDiePie
but not not the other stuff did you
enjoy the homogeny and racial purity of
the Japanese country
um no that was actually one of the major
issues
but other than that I mean there's a lot
of there's a lot of problems with Japan
but like
I mean of course of course there's a lot
of problems with your family we wrote
their [__] Constitution so like you
know there's there are a lot of like uh
hyper capitalist elements to to you know
Japanese modern society living they work
like 16 hour days and [__] don't they
like the work fun fact nuts Americans
work longer hours that's what I'm
talking about America Does It Better
number one baby number one well yeah
let's go well higher rate of suicide as
well in the United States of America we
topped Japan I thought they had number
one no South Korea is number one uh by
like a wide margin in comparison to
other oecd nations I'll never be like
I'll never look like
never look like jimin it has nothing to
do with it it's literally old people
killing themselves because they like
have to live in a [__] box and [__]
oh old people oh yeah Japan too actually
like it it's it's usually they were all
about respecting the elderly there
they are but they just put them in a
little box and then they're so sad they
kill themselves well I think like it's
the same [__] that you have here people
work themselves to death like literally
long hours long super long hours of
working oh you're you're
look at your your G fuel I mean not your
G fuel bro stop don't say that I'm gonna
hit the button
say it right say it right what is it g
fuel has lead in it bro we don't drink
that [__] what is that this is gamer sup
your Gamers up Gamers up Gamer sucks
look at your Gamers was invisible on the
on the oh it's just I can't believe you
okay hold on to me
stop stop
you shirt
gamer sup is a delicious drink it's
encouraging it's wonderful it's gamer
sub what's up
energizes me that's right you can go to
Gamers which is happening I have to I
have to knock that I believe when we
when we say that that naughty word
go to gamersup.gg H3 right
get 10 off for a free sample I don't
know I don't know how I don't know what
happened but you're you're like behind
you I'm looking at our studio right yeah
all of a sudden like this this green
wall was rolled behind you that was
crazy that was so fast
oh you're talking about no that's what
you saw the green wait it came back
again yeah normally it's that like I'm
in the studio right now everybody and
that's not there you know what I mean
usually that's not there it's just like
we have the regular background that you
see yeah I have it rigged on a button
whoa from the ceiling it's so fast
completely silent when it does it too
the green thing is actually that's
special effects the green behind you is
a live Roto skodering roto-scotering
yeah
yeah doing by the way I am wearing the
same shirt I liked it so much I wore it
twice
it's sick
um yeah
speaking of that we can get we can get
back to Japan in a second
I do wanna I I was I was literally like
ordering a bunch of stuff off the teddy
fresh website
release I saw a shirt and I was like yo
that shirt's sick he's like you want it
I'm like yeah yeah you can have all you
guys and then uh you know we decided to
to do this uh live instead but yeah I
want the I want the oil spill shirt we
already put that down this one the one
where yeah the oil spill pants I guess
we it has the shorts yeah sure yeah are
they long
um no what's the size like on those bad
boys because some of your shorts are a
little bit longer no they're not super
baggy they're like nylon so it's it's
like a normal kind of short all right
let's do double XL on the shorts then
Dorothy girthy I want that I want that
Teddy skull and crossbones sweater
triple XL which color that the red one
the red one yeah yeah I think we have
triple XL of this one
yes we do so Sam's got that actually
should I get a black one instead I feel
like I'm never gonna I mean the black
one's more wearable yeah let me get the
black one instead I would I would wear
the black one obviously for some people
this is the right choice all right black
you get that Sam yeah black black yeah I
want I want the send help shirt
also Triple A okay send help easy fun
easy clap yeah um the wash denim safety
pin shirt also triple XL
yeah I want your socks this one's really
cool we have made custom bobby pins I
love that
yeah there's another brand that I um
that I wear from sometimes that I guess
sometimes it also does like a
they do look at evil eye with a pin okay
no it's pretty chill um you want the
socks uh yeah I want the socks okay I
want the wash denim trucker jacket which
is sold out it seems wait
wait what it says sold out on the web oh
this is from last
oh we moved up oh we moved away this is
from oh we moved away from the from the
oh okay yeah I we could probably get you
one though we can look on it's all good
no I composed some levers you know ggs I
know the owner I lost the oh you know
the owner yeah well you know you look
fine yeah that's pretty sick I know damn
I know it really well actually oh by the
way this shirt is awesome too I didn't
know this was coming out this is a
graphic that I really like
laser focus on your goals baby this is
what illa made it's a I think she made
it from a sticker this is an
illustration but
she did a sticker and then she painted
over it and I thought it was cool I like
it thanks I do unfortunately have too
many t-shirts I feel that so anyway
teddyfresh.com there's all kinds of cool
stuff we actually made a skate deck for
the first time it's sold out I'm happy
to see which means we'll be making more
skate decks I love that but yeah it's
all ela's art
and then also I love that I mean it's
sold out I just think it's cool I just
want to show it off the front is pretty
cool too like the purple kind of veneer
do you call it
I I don't know what it's called I I'm
not like I'm not I don't skate
I'm just I'm talking about wood brother
oh manly stuff like wood
yeah you got a jewelry do you want to
like bro you got to go to Ben Shapiro
for that he's the king of of knowing
what to do with wood right I bought me a
two by four do you like you're like
earrings right is this your Vibe or not
I don't have any here I don't I don't do
that okay what about necklace I do love
necklaces yeah this one's kind of hype I
love that but is it gonna fit me it's a
real question
that's a good question
you have a small head blah blah blah
it's like yeah not when I
not when I need to put on one of these
necklaces turns out my my neck and head
are massive neck tiny head no my neck is
normal size in comparison to my head
it's just like it don't the people of
Japan were calling you Godzilla why my
neck
um Godzilla has a small head compared to
his body he actually kind of does yeah
Godzilla does not have a small head in
comparison he actually does and it does
oh that's still a classic [__] I
didn't realize we were okay so take a
look at this this is why this is why I
was I was happier in Japan
in Japan I was happier look at that the
man's got no neck that's like he's like
why are people saying audio serious
audio issue oh
was that real uh
this Godzilla looks more like big Ed
than let me investigate a scary one oh I
hear it what okay crackling
oh is that the button
do we have button issues hold on guys
static noise okay one second let me um
all right we got some static that's no
problem
we got no problem we take two weeks off
all of a sudden I know everything's
falling apart I know it
stand by people stand by so they can
hear us though right it just sounds like
[__] okay
um
I'll wait till the
the issue what the [__]
what
who's doing that I can't see because the
Godzilla is blocking me yeah the
Godzilla's blogging the monitor so let
me ask you this were the uh Japanese
people very are they assured people
in stature
oh they're still writing audio in the
chat I know but I might as well talk no
because there's a 20 second delay so
it's probably been going on for like
20 seconds yeah anyway
um oh [__] wait hold on I just found
something Ben Shapiro actually picked
this up outside Home Depot that's crazy
that's a real that man knows his wood
I'll tell you what
Dan is frantically checking switches
pushing buttons unplugging re-plugging
so are the Japanese people
stature did you power over them
there what the [__] Ethan what'd I do I
I don't know what's going on who
controls the the the the editing the
live editing what is happening I don't
see anything
the we paid Primo dollars to ensure that
my head looks larger at all times why is
the software not working
you're I don't know what you're talking
about the software keeps failing Ethan
it makes my head look
the size it looks normally when it's not
working I I got no clue what we're
talking about here
see that okay so go ahead like you said
okay
um
nothing nobody controls it
um I feel like I should suck on helium
Ian's messing with you it's very Ian
it's very rude don't make his head uh
his head is small enough as it is sorry
the technical issues seem to be
explaining visually as well yeah
we'll do one where his head's big at
least to make up for it
yeah make his head big if that yeah yeah
dude let's do that I want to see like
make it a little bit bigger let's see
what how that works let's see that big
yeah did you fix it Dan
I think
Dan is panicking that's not a good sign
Dan didn't couldn't even finish oh there
what do you think about that
that looks way more normal yeah I like
this
what's up this is my normal head size
what what's up what's up what now I'm
gonna stomp on some tiny Japanese people
what now Warhead
um Dan is frantically trying to fix he
couldn't even finish his sentence that's
a bad sign really I said I mean I think
like
oh you got it one two three four five
six seven you know these are these
things happen you know tell me about
this the stature of the Japanese people
I'm waiting for him to fix it so that
it's like not well I just want to fill
the voice okay well all right
um
Japan is five two that's their average
height did you know that
five two five two is the average height
of the Japanese population
yeah no like just it's mostly fixed now
um
okay mostly
I am I am still hearing like a little
bit of crackling what did you think the
issue was caused by uh honestly I'm not
sure uh I just re-connected a bunch of
stuff to make sure something hadn't
gotten loose so it's not the button you
don't think
um it's Pro I mean I don't think it's
the button itself but it's more all of
the changes that I had to make all
around the studio I see yeah
um I think it sounded pretty clean now
though and what would cause static in
the audio
uh
there's lots of things I'm still working
on fixing it Dan is uh is a work in
progress here guys he's in out oh I I
[__] up I'm sorry I apologize I was
looking at this no it was five to
seventy years ago
for the man seven years ago uh 70 years
ago now it's uh five seven so that's
actually like in America isn't it like
five eight
I think they've grown a lot over the
past 70 years I don't know how ever I
think they're just eating meat instead
of rice
more meat maybe that's what I've read
that could be because back in the day
they you know they're saying audio is
good now okay average height of American
man on the beach
advocate of an American
man
is 5 10 actually yeah
so did you feel super like it's
especially tall over there yeah so
there's a lot of there's a lot of issues
in Japan with respect to like xenophobia
with respect to like obviously being
hyper capitalist all that sort of stuff
um but then the other issue for me in
particular was the reality that uh I
can't fit into anything doorways
um that sort of stuff was all right it's
like not the worst because I can't
really fit into anything in America
either okay usually like yeah in Japan
it's a little bit smaller okay for sure
but overall it wasn't like that much of
a gigantic burden I mean it was kind of
funny so what is it that was too small
for you clothing clothing I grew up
loving uh you know like Japanese denim
Japanese designers all these like
wonderful brands that have come out of
Japan to America engineered garments
Capital like there's so many there's so
many sick new and older Japanese brands
these are all like usually
um since uh post World War II era Japan
like there's been a hyper focus on uh
American culture and an American fashion
American garments which uh ironically I
also personally love which speaking of
which I just uh launched my America yeah
let's plug that
um Americorps collection just came out
this is by the way the tallest Japanese
person ever
I wonder where he shops he's still alive
68 he might be that's pretty good no
he's still alive he's like a salaryman
now
really just as a day job yeah I watched
like a mini doc on his life before I
went to Japan so
um you got you probably need to shop at
like the big and wide stores you know
what I mean like yeah but I don't want
that I want like the I want like the
fashion [__] yeah well sucks to be tall
flavors and and not every brand is like
uh you know ideology or Teddy fresh uh
serving all the way up to Triple XL you
know what I'm saying let me see this how
do you like the website that's fire I
like I literally I love the um yeah I
always like the Myspace callbacks yeah
we did it uh every drop we changed the
entire aesthetic and this one is like uh
like a early 2000s uh website
shop now did I just scroll down yeah you
scroll down yeah camo whoa dude you're
strapped watch out conservatives no
people were people were clowning on me
because they were like wow oh my God
there's no sights on this it's like
Airsoft I'm like yeah dude I didn't
Source the gun and everyone was making
it seem like you know all you're you're
hyper focusing on the gut aesthetic
first of all
um I I do enjoy shooting guns I've
talked about it quite frequently I've
shot guns on camera and oh you see that
what's that what's that it's a refresh
bracelet yeah dude nice thank you
um
anyway people are always like
people
are always like uh people get like very
very protective and gatekeeping over
guns and gun culture and I'm like first
of all you know just as well as I do if
you know anything about gun culture like
there's a lot of tactical [__]
too this is the exact opposite I guess
of being like hyper hyper tactical like
doing tactical [__] John Brown uh John
Brown is a radical abolitionist
America's first domestic terrorist
doesn't matter hey hey represent John
Brown in the
yeah John Brown in the house but like he
was a domestic terrorist uh that that
you know focused on
uh abolishing slavery before the Civil
War
um some say that uh his arrest his
subsequent arrests by Robert E Lee as a
matter of fact after his uh Bill attempt
at Harpers Ferry
um
and his execution for treason he was
hanged for treason uh that was uh that
was what the Catalyst was for everyone
in the Abolitionist North to to
recognize that like hey this is not
gonna happen through peaceful means
that's it yeah represent John Brown yeah
he was a crazy guy who what are we
storming when our John Brown
hoodies and shirts so where are we
talking about that it's more so like I'm
I I love American culture I'm fascinated
with American culture and I think that
there's a lot of good that has happened
throughout American history as well as
the bad and I think John Brown
represents uh one of those things that's
like fascinating for me
um he's like you know white guy uh
fought
uh with blood paid in blood to to uh
free African slaves okay and I I think
that's good so who are we killing the
southern no there's no one you're not
killing me I don't know you got me
outside on the John Brown
for for me it's it's just represents of
like a lot of a lot of the yee like real
tree camo style [__] which by the way
this is not real tree this is our own
patented design I guess we had to make
our own wait so there's actually really
patted in because I saw the skull here
it looks yeah yeah yeah there's like
there's like little Easter eggs
everywhere inside of it did you guys
actually patent the design I don't think
it's I mean I probably not I don't know
that's the whole process but I just
oversaw the creative part but
um we had to make our own uh pattern
you guys see that looks sick everything
came out really good but yeah I think
for me it's like uh it's not just about
uh you know
redneck culture doesn't
have to always be about like right-wing
conservatism you know it is we're up
we're reappropriating pretty much yeah
my culture's not your prom dress type
[__] well there it is guys shop it at
ideology.shop Link in the description
all right we got to kind of we gotta hit
the ground running so to speak because I
have a heart out today actually I am
going to the dermatologist did you
notice I've got like crazy puffy eyes I
did not notice that I thought you were
just kind of sleepy I got a rash and
I've been taking a ton of Benadryl and I
was hoping it'd be better this morning
it's not it's worse
tell them what it's from
I I listen I don't know what it's from
but it might be from eating beef burger
shut the [__] up it's I swear to God
it's all I ate yesterday and I started
developing it last night oh my Lord that
was two days ago now obviously I don't
know
and I could never say that Beast Burger
gave me a rash
but I think Beast Burger gave me a wrap
which one which Burger I got everything
you got everything taste test what are
the what are the Beast Burger Burgers
like was it was it the Dream Burger like
who who which content creator
specifically gave you the rash you think
it was Mr Beast for sure yeah it was a
Mr Beast one oh no no I was anyway so
let's so anyway let's move on I gotta
leave at like 12
30. I don't know Lena will tell me
But A lot's happened we got a lot to get
to
uh first of all something that I think
we always like to touch on is the
updates with Donald Trump's uh nicknames
for DeSantis today he's established or
he's testing out tiny d
ude santis very good he also floated
Ron dishonest I love it I don't like
that it's honest not bad but I don't
like it as much tiny D's very good
meatball Ron is the best so he disavowed
meatball along he says that was never in
the running meatball Ron
um but also there's Ron D establishment
that one seems a little forced
he needs to stay away from like words
with uh too many letters in them too
many syllables because he's look you're
trying to Market to an audience of of
baboons right and like if you make it
too convoluted too complicated they're
just gonna be like I don't [__] uh
deep State Ron why is he not taking our
freaking suggestion because State Ron
yeah I don't know I wonder why Ron The
Establishment is like
it actually hits him on like an a
genuine talking point though unlike many
of the other ones so that's he's got to
find a way to make that message more
clear in my opinion because Rhonda
santis is the establishment he's just
LARPing as like a trumpian style a
republican well I guess Trump is also
technically this stuff it doesn't even
matter what's true that's that's just he
could do anything with these names you
know I mean he could do Ron de
leprechaun they'd be like in leprechauns
true which is why meatball ROM is so
good yeah I liked meatballs because it's
like anti-italian slander you know what
I mean like
hey the culture War since you were gone
was the Hershey's
heard she responds to backlash over
women's day campaign featuring trans
activists did you see that like there
was a whole conservative meltdown
because they this was a Canadian program
they did to celebrate women's day and
they featured a trans activist her house
and there was like a whole uh culture
War Fallout in fact
our favorite people over at the daily
wire
are now launching in competition not
just with Hershey's but with Mr Beast
okay and that is where the real problem
arises what no they're not they made
their own chocolate feastables
feastables is not collaborating with the
daily watch no I mean they're they're
competing in the chocolate Market oh
okay I thought you were making it seem
like no Mr Beast daily wire feastables
collab was coming out or something like
transphobia chocolate
so this is the co-creator of daily wire
with Ben Benny boy stop giving your
money to woke chocolate companies that
hate you give it to me instead
this man is trying to make money in
chocolate I can't imagine that there's
like a lot of money to make there but
let's see International women's day is
upon us again I mean and I love an
internet wait this is one thing that's
like sick about like chocolate is that
like they definitely are using slaves so
I'm I feel like that's a that's a real
big bonus for the daily wire like daily
wires like we're doing slavery which is
why we got into it like we're not even
gonna make money out of this we just
love using child slaves most companies
be like yo we need to audit the
manufacturers to make sure they're not
using child slaves he's like no no no no
I want the child slaves I forgot to
mention
Supreme Court protected child slaves and
by that I don't mean the Supreme Court
is protecting the child slaves I mean
the Supreme Court is protecting the
rights of international American
corporations using child slave labor
that is a supreme court kids need income
yeah nobody wants to work anymore I mean
good thing that uh you know child
slavery used to be for like I don't know
uh for the past like 20 30 years child
slavery was kind of like a you know
Global South Third World victims of
colonial exploitation uh country type
thing but many states in the United
States of America are also rolling back
child labor laws child labor protections
specifically so we can have our own
child slaves dude there was a huge
Scandal recently about child slaves in
America or child child laborers like I I
was reading uh they're they're migrant
workers they come yeah looking for work
but they put them in super dangerous
jobs
and like I find them are dying I find
that to be awesome because uh you know
it happened in the Alabama Hyundai uh
facilities right
um and then it came out according to the
uh investigations conducted by uh I
believe it was the nlrb uh that uh
multiple companies were also utilizing
like sanitation services that had like
children uh operating with uh children
like oh we're talking 13 14 year olds by
the way and
um instead of looking at that and going
this is insane how the [__] is this
happening
um a bunch of States decided let's just
roll back child labor laws I think I
agree Hitler oh we need workers and
these kids need money because listen
I'm not giving my kids money for that
school lunch hell no that price went up
you know that 250 Pizza dollar slice 250
dollar slices now five dollars and I am
saying get a [__] job now Theodore's
already working in the coal mine and
he's three and a half what's your excuse
exactly I I have none
oh but anyway daily wire is pro-child
slavery and that's what they're after
here International women's day is upon
us again
and I love an international woman but
our friends over at Hershey's they don't
even know what a woman is they've hired
a biological male to be the spokesperson
for their women's day campaign and
they're calling that campaign and I
swear I'm not making this up her she
I mean it's kind of close this wait go
back go back just real quick to the to
the shot of all three of them yeah
making this up brother you are literally
shorter than the biological female next
to you you know what I mean why is it
the gender binary like the gender is a
binary guys are always like barely
fitting in the same [__] binary that
they're trying to advocate for also
Michael Knowles here is like his Butler
yeah like his little slave boy it's
always weird to see that kind of thing
uh
Brad Cooper looks good though good for
her
I feel like she's eventually going to
come to her senses to realize that's uh
that's a female femshabibo
oh she has a show yeah she's like
they're in yeah yeah she's like they're
young uh content creator that's like
supposed to be uh youth facing okay we
love that for her because she's like a
fake live stream that's not a real live
stream and like acts like she's
responding to chat really yeah that's
fake because it's not a live stream they
just they it's it's vods it's not even
involved like it's it's like a YouTube
video but it's uh shot in a way where
like she's like kind of she is shot in a
way like she's responding to a live chat
I wonder why they do that oh I wonder if
the seems like there's a very successful
political content creator out there that
does that so they just basically ripped
it you think they're ripping you off I
mean I don't give a [__] whatever
you think she's ripping you off no I
mean I don't care there's no IP or
anything it's not like no no no you
create she's ripping you off
I did not say that I said something
along those lines and I think she made a
video about it and when like her fan
base was very upset at me
I've never seen or heard of her so I
guess she's not that popular but anyway
here's Michael noet look at this Michael
Knowles here who's this little slave boy
I love that for him
she
Hershey it's not that bad it's kind of
clever I mean I I don't know it's a
little cringy but it's not like it's
also kind of clever it's humiliating and
it's the reason that I'm launching
Jeremy's chocolate we have two kinds
it's like bro what do you know about
chocolate like just because trans people
exist doesn't mean that you get to like
make good chocolate
I
it doesn't matter the the product could
be cardboard they're they're not banking
on it tasting good they're banking on it
being anti-trans which is so it's insane
to me that now it nowadays it's just
like yeah this this is called [__] trans
people uh underwear you know what I mean
wear this if you want to [__] tell
everybody you hate trans people the
grift is so on display here it's like oh
well here's a culture War thing now I'm
gonna make money from it you don't need
to send me money to prove which is how
much you hate woke cult culture the
irony is they're putting the cart before
the horse right like this is why you
know the Gina Carano special uh the the
movies that they've come out with on The
Daily wire kind of suck and nobody wants
to watch it and they gross like 800 in
the first weekend box office right
um because
these companies make a product and then
they Market it sometimes in a
misogynistic fashion and then sometimes
in this like now in this era in a very
uh you know
[__] pandering Pro Trans Pro women
message right but that's just marketing
like ultimately they still have the
product so if your entire goal is to
just basically only do marketing without
ever focusing on the product without
ever establishing yourself as a brand
then that's all you're doing you're just
like a a marketing company well they
developed a chocolate bar in like a week
which so I'll tell you what they did a
hundred percent they went to an existing
Chocolate Factory and said hey can you
put our label on yours and that's what
happens that's how you make your own
chocolate bar in a week it could even be
Hershey's let's be real the chocolate
company they made it probably owned by
her shoes yeah also Hershey's is awful
like literally awful yeah it tastes like
doo-doo it tastes like vomit because of
a chemical that they like purposely left
in because it gives a unique taste I
guess it is unique yeah uniquely vomit
inducing Taste of vomit so I don't know
why the [__] like I mean I would not go
to the Hershey's factory is what I'm
saying
from what I can see
yes from what I can see on the Hershey's
uh Facebook page their first promotion
of the Hershey thing was February 20th
oh they've been going out for this we've
been going on for this yeah but um that
one doesn't look like it includes
the trans bar so it looks like that
actually got introduced like you said
just like a week or two ago yeah it
didn't even get introduced in America
like you guys were saying it was in
Canada right because yeah and it's
Canada and look at this you can that bar
that looks like a prop dude like come on
ain't no chocolate yeah I don't think
they I don't think they have the product
but in this day and age because of like
ghost kitchens and because of the way
that like you can basically do white
glow production for pretty much anything
um
you can you can act like you have a
brand you can act like you have a
product before you even actually have
your [__] hands on the product and
basically do Drop Shipping for anything
um
and yeah and that's what they're doing
that's why everybody wants to become an
influencer Jeremy
we have two kinds
she her
and he him
one of them's got nuts if you need me to
tell you which one it is
keep giving your money to her this guy
is such a little [__] pieces why do
you think that was a good face to make
he's crazy why did nobody tell him don't
make that face dog it's very scary
Michael stop you're scaring the hoes nah
bro I don't like Jeremy either thanks
but if you're tired of giving your money
to what corporations to hate you and
you're looking for a delicious chocolate
bar from a company that actually wants
your business head over to
ihatehersheys.com and remember Jeremy's
chocolate today let's go there I want to
see how much their bars are I'm sorry
there's no [__] shot this is like a
viable business no right exactly it's
like people aren't they're not trying to
like just nobody wants to buy chocolate
from you Jeremy I'm sorry
Jeremy
I hate her
she's do you spell it right with the S
or she Hershey's this is why I'm Pro Mr
Beast chocolate okay I'm on Team
feastable guys
oh you gotta buy in bulk brother oh my
God four packs is 25 actually not that
bad is it four candy bars
four chocolate bars for 20 show
Brandon's America wait how is that a
good deal no that's that's insanely it's
one chocolate bar here's the expensive I
mean how much does a Hershey's bar cost
99 Cents baby is it still 99 I don't
know I mean that you just made that up
chocolate it can't be much more than
that I mean who's paying for it more
than that I don't know the last time
I've bought it I know for sure is how a
chocolate bar cut doesn't cost
six bucks seven dollars I think isn't
that like feastables uh free school's
like the same no feasible is like no
Hershey's chocolate milk uh candy bar
six count is six dollars and 39 cents
right now at Target what a deal I
[__] told you 100 bucks for a 24 hour
telling you dude Joe Brandon's America
inflation has hit all even including but
not limited to vomit tasting candy yeah
they got fair trade cocoa butter you
dudes fair trade organic that sounds
pretty weak yeah why are they doing this
bear trade how about some unfair trade
what's going on doing bad deals dude but
I'm saying they got the woke ingredients
yeah
we did not eviscerate the global South
so we could not take advantage of child
slavery my man what the [__] going on
it's one of the most hyper exploitative
Industries out there what is this fair
trade nonsense soy free don't you're
rest assured my friend I think that's
for allergies by the way I don't think
that's like I don't think I don't think
it's soy free I don't think they specify
that because they're like oh this is soy
free I think Jeremy's chocolate bro
you know I'm telling you it's this is
weak sauce okay especially when you got
the Supreme Court allowing Nestle and
Hershey and all these other companies to
like continue using uh third-party
contracted of course not directly but
third-party contracted child slavery
um and these guys are doing fair trade
[__] everyone in the comments is
like yo where's the ingredient list how
do you make sure it doesn't include seed
oil
yeah right anyway okay so there it is
daily wire is again riding the
uh riding the the
wave the Griffin yeah the Griff train is
is going all Speed Ahead so we'd love
that for them
thank you yes also
um
Don Jr
oh the the actual bars I'm so sorry I
gotta go back I was wrong the actual
Hershey's milk chocolate candy bar full
size
1.55 ounces bar like the same ones are
one dollar and 24 cents at Walmart thank
you what I was looking at was a pack
exactly this band's trying to sell me a
chocolate bar for like seven and a half
dollars yeah yeah I was wrong I was so
wrong about that so here one with
almonds is two dollars so here's um
speaking of chocolate here's Don Jr
doing a Willy Wonka leftovers
check under your seats check under your
seats if they're happy go
sh no I'm not joking that's a VIP ticket
to my father's Chocolate Factory no he
goes uh uh I hate Oprah but yo she kind
of got good ideas
reception
tomorrow at CPAC
uh check under there it is so we're
doing a little bit of a Willy Wonka out
there so the chocolate game is running
deep
instead of chocolate the factories the
racism Factory got him ship it out baby
package it up uh moving on I want to
talk about CPAC which is the
conservative political action conference
this is and correct me if I'm wrong
Hassan
the biggest the most important
conservative kind of like Meeting of
Minds is that right yeah but it it
dramatically fell off it did uh it fell
off a lot because there's a division
happening within the Republican Party
while CPAC was happening uh Club for
Growth which is like the Koch brothers
backed like institutionalist Republicans
uh you know who who do uh genuinely
undermine American democracy every step
of the way like they are significantly
better terrorists than like Osama Bin
Laden ever could dream of those guys
were running their own show down in
Florida
and you know you understand who they're
uh you know you understand who their dog
in the fight is basically so so there's
this Rift within the Republican Party
currently and I think that Rift consists
of the Ron DeSantis Camp of like
institutionalist Republicans who just
like don't want to rock the boat and
keep want to undermining like social
safety nets and and you know do
deregulation and stuff but like
not have it get too far out of hand
someone so that like liberals actually
react to it and and are forced into
action you know what I mean because
they're like really angry yeah
um and they believe that Ron DeSantis
will be that guy to give them like a
little bit just enough culture War
issues but
um still maintain uh a a
a delicate balance where they're able to
like effectively legislate and I think
Ron DeSantis unlike Donald Trump is is a
party guy he is a political machine guy
whereas Don Donald Trump can sometimes
uh say insane stuff from the bully
pulpit and is uh somewhat uncontrollable
because he is mostly just fueled by his
narcissistic desires self-preservation
and the like so he'll he'll throw like
Republicans under the bus in a way that
Ron DeSantis never would right so that's
why there's this riff now and because
there's this Rift
um CPAC was not as well attended did you
see the video of the Trump uh the Trump
speech at Sea fact that the auditorium
was was not even fully it wasn't full I
think we must have that in here I've got
some highlights
but yeah I mean that that gap between
DeSantis and Trump is going to be what
makes this all so fun to watch this
coming uh primary but
there was some really incredible things
and the point I say is CPAC really does
represent I think
popular opinions within the Conservative
Republican party and so when they have
someone who like Michael Knowles who is
I want to put this in in terms that is
actually accurate he is a
genocidal freak
he is like a
actual genocidal yeah [__] yeah
Gremlin not only is he a gremlin uh and
and a lap dog of of this Jeremy boring
guy but he also is like trying to do his
own like Matt Walsh [__] like he this is
him biting Matt Walsh's aesthetic of
like uh you know wanting to eradicate
trans people you know what I mean so
here's a speech that he delivered on the
floor of CPAC the most popular uh
Republican you know coming of great
minds check this out there can be no
trigger warning genocide yeah Middle Way
in dealing with transgenderism it is all
or nothing if transgenderism is true if
men really can become women then it's
true for everybody of all ages if
transgenderism is false as it is if men
really can't become women as they cannot
then it's false for everybody too
and if it's false
then we should not indulge it
especially since that Indulgence
requires taking away the rights and
Customs he's so self-assured he thinks
he's been false he's such a [__] look at
his face he's like I'm killing it right
now I'm killing the speech uh totally
yes attention starts taking away the
rights and customs of so many people how
the [__] do trans people take away the
rights and Customs like that's even a
stretch I
I don't even know what well they can't
make they can't make a real argument
about anything so they just have to make
[__] up the idea is always the same it's
like the existence of of black people in
white spaces somehow takes away from
white people's rights and privileges
when that's not the case right same with
gay people same with trans people people
are absorbing our rights ladies and
gentlemen I mean the the red pill guys
do a similar thing when they talk about
like women in the workplace taking away
the rights and Liberties of men because
women and men should know no but at
least like there's some coherent
argument in that like oh they're
replacing men because you can if you
have one employment spot it could be a
man or a woman the trans thing I don't
get what is he implying good women are
marrying trans and they I just don't get
the what's being replaced
um what's being replaced is I mean it's
the same argument that Nazis used also
directly against trans people as well
fun fact that's what a lot of people
that is fine yeah that like Nazis
weren't exactly too fond of trans people
either uh the first famous book burning
that everybody knows about was uh
actually a uh you know trans medical
research that they burned it's the first
famous like documented book burning that
the Nazis did anyway
um but their argument is that trans
people existing creates moral degeneracy
and perversion like they are an affront
the god uh they are uh destroying social
norms and constructs that hold Western
Civilization together okay and that uh
when you see a trans person in society
in in public
um and and you normalize that kind of
behavior more people will become trans
just like they made the exact same
argument about about homosexuality
uh which uh is no longer as fashionable
or as appropriate to do so but they're
still trying to bring that back too
because it's not just about trans people
it's about like whatever they decide the
norm is and whoever is deviating from
that is is abhorrent okay and must be
eradicated okay I see the point it is
interesting I think if you accumulate
how much thought goes into trans people
between Jordan Peterson Michael Knowles
and uh who's that other uh solo Matt
Walsh yeah Matt Walsh I mean these guys
collectively are talking and thinking
about trans people probably more than
the whole world combined yeah no they
got Trans on the mind all the time
that's why I call it like a like a
diagnosable mental
okay give me a second
there's no audio
has that been an issue at all
no that's me right now
wait I just played with the audio sound
like Play It Again
yeah it's back has that been an issue at
all it sounds fine there [__]
so we're good sorry guys we're having
some tech issues here but it seems to be
resolved
um
so as I was saying we are now they're
saying no audio again we can hear now
for a second okay now it's back okay
just open the stream let's hear what it
sounds like okay
um
sounds fine yeah
the buttons out Dan oh we're flying
we're flying without protection
you had to kill the button to fix the
audio Yeah I mean it's a cabling issue
and there's really nothing like I was
doing my best to fix it while and it
kept fixing but then getting bad again
um and so now I've just bypassed the
entire thing we're streaming from Ian's
computer directly now we just ripped off
the condom ripped off the con raw
dogging baby
you can do it
[Applause]
I believe in you also what's insane
about this is that like uh you know you
you can say whatever the [__] you want
about the NRA or whatever right and then
you immediately get punished for it
because servers go [__] ape mode on
you yeah but for some reason Michael
Knowles can say what he's about to say
let's watch and then and then we'll talk
about the subsequent lack of background
percentage
then for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely the whole
Preposterous ideology at every level
yeah so so the way I interpret that is
that when you're talking about
the word eradicate first of all invokes
like Nazi Final Solution yeah and he
says transgenderism which of course is
the property the intrinsic property of a
person so to me he's just straight up
calling for to kill Roundup and kill
trans people
I mean that's the way I interpreted it
and I think a lot of people interpret it
that way I mean because that's what he
meant that's what he said he meant we
must eradicate transgenderism there is
no peaceful solution to eradicate
transgenderism because let's say your
goal is to eliminate trans people from
public spaces but trans people are still
going to exist regardless
um what do you do you have to become
violent at a certain point uh if the
state is not violent then people take
matters in their own hands like the Q
nightclub shooting that happened uh
obviously that's kind of what they want
to happen regardless while they're
simultaneously uh utilizing the state
legislatures all around the country to
eradicate trans people by stopping them
from transitioning by by punishing
doctors by punishing transparents by
punishing trans children by punishing
anyone and everyone who is trans to make
medical decisions like stopping them
from making medical decisions that
genuinely would improve their lives
um and and you know that's it that's
that's their very clear stated agenda
because there's no peaceful way to like
stop trans people from existing right
you can't do that you can't be like oh
yeah like right you know we gotta
eradicate uh you know Jewish mentality
from existence is not something you can
[__] say because so his defense on
this as people rightly got a little bit
freaked out and again I remind you that
this is said loudly and proudly on the
and the national stage for conservatives
to cheering
he insists that he wants to eradicate
transgenderism as an ideology not
eradicate trans people yeah it's like
saying I'm gonna Outlaw Judaism
not Jews just Judaism yeah yeah yeah no
that makes sense not really totally come
on guys we're just you know we're not
doing anything crazy I mean come on go
on Hulk Hogan with a [__] but the
entire point of that is that like
eradicate Judaism it plays along with
like the dehumanization right like
he thinks that trans people are an
aberration that must be excised that is
not like a real thing they're just like
crazy people that we need to uh you know
play this song and dance with
but even if that was the case then you
know you could just like leave trans
people alone which by the way that isn't
the case for the record obviously but
even if that was the case you would just
like leave them alone that's a good idea
so and yet that's not enough because
these guys are bullies that's it they're
weak people all the time they're more
they're worse than bullies I mean this
shocked me really like I mean they're
genocidal but I'm saying like I'm using
simpler terms so that like uh people in
the margins can comprehend it too you
are not a man
if you go after people who are otherwise
uh not able to defend themselves look at
this you are not a manager's face this
is not photoshopped you're you're a weak
person you are barely a person you're
barely a [__] human being dude his
smile is straight up like there's
invisible fingers forcing a joke bro he
looks like the you know what he looks
like he looks like the [__] like uh
what is it like the claymation
stop-motion Christmas
uh the Christmas specials that they used
to play like the elf he's an elfish
little Al fish you know what I'm talking
about Santa's Little Helper
are you talking you're not talking about
the Grinch are you no no no what is the
claymation uh stop motion like Christmas
special with like elves and like Rudolph
the Red Nose yeah Reindeer the Hermie
Rankin bass yeah Rankin bass it's just
called Rudolph the red-nosis was he the
was he the guy in that who wanted to uh
eradicate reindeers no bro he looks like
one of the elves like his face looks oh
I guess not really smart don't they
smile
I'm trying to find I think I know what
you're talking about find a photo of one
of these [__] elves smiling and I
promise you Wallace a grimace
yeah I see that it does have that
I can't wipe the smile off my face
Batman
it's like I was born to laugh he does he
has he has claymation smile maybe uh
Snow Miser
can we get a Snow Miser here a Snow
Miser perhaps a Snow Miser
yeah claymation smile is like very
specific that's what his his smile looks
like a claymation smile
oh
yes so um what anyway what I felt
looking at him listening to this speech
is that
this is
the face of the American fascist like
this is happening in America
yeah they found their scapegoat they're
willing to be violent to eradicate to
eradicate
and
um this is this is what it is this I
think their platform is becoming more
and more fascist
and they've got their scapegoat now and
they're ready to be violent and people
are on the national stage cheering about
eradicating transgenderism
of course he is a giant [__]
piece of [__] coward
and he's threatening to sue people now
just cracks me up yeah she packs bigger
calls for transgender people to be
eradicated which is like literally
that's what he did right and then uh he
said this is suable this is libel this
is slander like I will you will be
hearing from my [__] lawyers it's
like you're you're such a baby you're
such a petulant little cowardly [__]
here he is here he is on Twitter this is
his uh Twitter account he says this
headline is libelous I demand a
retraction hey Michael Knowles
you want to eradicate trans people yeah
there is no like oh he's like no I meant
transgenderism it's like oh dude got it
okay
yeah so this is the face of American
fascism right here he's left the ism on
it so it's different it's not actually
like trans people he's talking about
he's talking about transgenderists
whatever the [__] that means he's like
no you don't understand I made up a term
and I'm I'm actually attacking the
made-up thing that I uh that I'm talking
about we must eradicate
we must eradicate don't do it hamburger
patties don't do it okay don't I know
you want to do it we must eradicate
we've got the button don't worry no we
don't have the button just kidding we
don't have a bunion got you guys
he scares me he's actually such a
[__] psychotic freak he's not even
he's not even like riding as hard as as
Matt Walsh is he's just trying to do the
Matt Walsh thing now because he's like
he's a he's like not even the third best
[__] guy at Daily wire dude holy [__]
bottom tier yeah do you think Matt Walsh
is jealous
of all the attention that he's all the
transphobia there's a competition this
is like I feel like they are this is
like Google's versus uh
I don't know who who's another prominent
I'm glad that you brought up I'm glad
that you brought up a monopoly when
talking about competition well Google
well they're competing amongst each
other for the favor no he was trying to
say Gobles uh it just came out as Google
I didn't say Google
you kind of did Oh I thought you said
no bro it's like not or it was kind of
like Google Google
so anyway oh mindfura I'm the best
transfer please love me yeah it's uh
that's Himmler I want to kill all the
trans people more than him more and more
I promise I'm being so mean I'm being
such a meaningful opinion now please
Benny boy put on the strap on uh put on
the [__] sleeve oh your [__] is too
small to penetrate me oh my God
anyway Rolling Stone High uh uh uh
updated their headline after being
threatened with a lawsuit they said see
pack speaker calls for eradication of
transgenderism and somehow claims he's
not calling for elimination of
transgender people yeah that's awesome
also love that they didn't use his name
in the headline kind of a kind of fire
and also it's under the category of evil
which apparently is a section of Rolling
Stones
[Laughter]
yeah let me just see what's going on in
evil today and the evil vertical yeah oh
better that than [__] what Breitbart
used to have which was black crime yeah
that one's pretty good right yeah when
Ben Shapiro worked there by the way fun
fact Ben Shapiro left Breitbart because
he was like I couldn't stand the
anti-Semitism that was happening when
the alt-right took over Breitbart it's
like [__] when you worked there
there was literally a tag called black
crime that is that is [__] crazy yeah
it's almost like and that they're giving
away the game in the headline they're
like here's our propaganda we're just
talking about black crime yeah take out
all the other crime that you don't want
to hear about
here's Michael Knowles saying that uh
I'm pleased to see The Daily Beast
lawyer scrambled to make them stealth
edit their defamatory headline about me
unfortunately this tweak does not
constitute a retraction of the article
which remains libelous Michael knows his
transgender must be eradicated this is
genocidal
I mean it is it is genocidal I never
said that dude just own your [__] why
you can't get such a baby because like
he can't because it's like not fully
institutionalized yet it's the same
attitude that like uh you know racist
people have when
when you when you ask like uh Nazis they
won't say that they're Nazis until they
reach that final Point they'll just say
like Oh I'm a white identitarian or I'm
just trying to defend white people I'm
just trying to stop white genocide from
happening because they recognize that
like deep down inside being considered a
bigoted person is not a good thing and
you can't reach out as to as broad an
audience as possible
new study that came out uh an ipsos poll
actually just came out uh yesterday USA
Today and ipsos conducted a poll where
they looked at the word woke and what uh
that what kind of was it a positive
image that it invoked or a negative one
and it turns out 59 of Americans
consider woke to be you know positive
thing or they consider it to be
um were they considered to be someone
who is social justice-minded and only 36
percent of Americans consider it to be
like a smarmy that is actually a
surprise over corrective and that really
is a great snapshot for you to just like
pull yourself away from the extremely
online space for a brief moment and take
a look at like what people who use
landlines think you know what I mean
that is interesting and all of a sudden
you get a way different picture
all right same goes for uh trans issues
in general I talk to trans activists all
the time including Aaron who's a
wonderful journalist who's on that
article
um I did a uh I was a part of a charity
drive alongside uh Juniper uh also known
as transgender Marxist where uh we
talked to some you know uh you know we
talked to a Trans State Legislature a
state legislator and numerous other
trans journalists and like what everyone
recognizes within the uh trans activism
Community as well is that like
for the most part Americans just kind of
have apathy towards trans people like
the normative position for a lot of
Americans is just like yeah I don't
really get it but like I don't care you
know what I mean that's what the normies
think these people are basically honing
in on transphobia as their main message
as their main movement
um because they are getting reinforced
from the cycle of hatred that they see
from extremely online spaces that's what
they're cutting legislation off of that
and also the psychotic like uh
right-wing Christian uh lawyer Network
as uh another trans uh hacktivist
recently exposed Mother Jones wrote an
article about this uh yesterday that
there's this deep network of anti-trans
movement like groups Christian lawyers
you know protecting the family group or
whatever the [__] uh uh you know groups
like this that directly have a line of
communication with State legislatures
and they play a role in like crafting
the messaging and play a role in selling
the the transphobic bills
that are getting pushed through and and
almost every single state with the
exception of like really blue ones
right now like they're they're this is
very deliberate and I I liken it to the
abortion the anti-abortion movement in
this country it took like around 35 40
years for that to actually uh finally
become uh
criminalized again right
um but they're doing that with trans
people and it doesn't even matter if
people have apathy it doesn't even
matter if people genuinely do care about
protecting abortion for example
ultimately these guys will use
extra-legal uh circumstances and and
push through their their narrative push
through their uh nefarious agenda their
violent agenda uh no matter what it
takes even if it does not uh appeal to
the sensibilities of the broader
population
uh Matt Walsh not he doesn't want to be
outdone as you noted but from Michael
Knowles so he quickly went to Twitter to
win back
daddy Benny boy
they said we were minding our own
business when suddenly the trans
movement came along and demanded that we
totally abandoned biology common sense
and Truth itself for its sake
our war against this Scourge is a
defensive struggle they started it they
wanted this fight
now they have it yeah they just can't
leave trans people alone for some
[__] reason you started it that's
like pretty that's like the Jews brought
this on themselves yeah that was 100
Nazi Playbook [__] yeah exactly like uh
establish an enemy
uh an enemy that is both strong and weak
at all times right
um and and vilify them endlessly
dehumanize them endlessly make them out
to be the the villains of every single
thing that you feel and in a society
where people are uh experiencing
economic instability volatility and
resentment and they have no good
prescriptions because any kind of
left-wing commentary is completely
removed from uh most liberal spaces as
well within media uh and the only thing
that you hear is like these guys making
outside of the bachons
you know we we can we can move to this
as a perfect parallel so listen to this
Joseph
Gilberts
[__] him he was of course a very famous
Nazi the head of propaganda he said this
why are you calling him a Nazi
I think he was literally a member of the
Nazi wait hold on hold on did he say he
was a Nazi I think so yeah okay I don't
know I don't know you need to give me
more conclusive evidence Hitler no he
was literally member of the Nazi party I
don't know man what's next are you gonna
say Kanye West is a Nazi like come on
yeah I mean well if that one's more
debatable but I don't think anymore
Nazis all the time yeah he said this
about Jews
now once again let's read this tweet
he says we're minding our business with
suddenly transmitted came along demanded
that we totally abandoned biology Common
Sense truth itself our Wars with the
scourge is a defensive struggle they
started it they wanted this fight now
they have it
now let's go over to what
Goebbels said about uh the Jews he said
the Jews wanted the war and now they
have it referring to Nazi propaganda
scheme to shift the blame for the world
war onto European Jews
the Jews bore the brunt of the Nazis
first
no is that it I mean but that that's
that's Verbatim what he said yeah the
Jews wanted the war now they have it
it's like you know it's so Preposterous
to look at now you know everybody agrees
what a [__] how crazy this was yeah here
it is happening right now in America
it's not the hatred that really offends
me it's the plagiarism oh yeah you know
it's just like distasteful yeah that you
would just uh rip
uh this this guy that uh Ethan is
calling a Nazi well he was a member he
was literally a member of the Nazi party
oh wow once again no diversity of ideas
here no he he and well he was like
Hitler's best friend wow are you saying
that people with differing opinions
can't be friends with one another got
them
no they had the same opinion
you don't know that you weren't there
you weren't there were you and don't
know that when Hitler and Gobles was
talking strategy yeah
it's just a fact in my opinion it's uh
gobo's hate for the Jews is greatly
exaggerated yeah
yeah so Matt Walsh taking a play out of
the Nazi handbook almost verbatim so
that's [__] just disturbing you know
what I mean
I'll show the leftovers which is a great
show by the way thank you so much yeah I
appreciate that so there that's what's
going on at CPAC ladies and gentlemen
the in the National platform for
conservatives yeah but you know the good
of that is that the conservative party
is basically imploding and uh you know
uh it's literally because of this
because there's a very active part of
the base that demands more and more
violent rhetoric because they're like
we're Christian fascists like please
give us some give us crumbs of Christian
fascism please and then there's the
other side that's like I just want to
make sure that you know we can slowly
but surely melt poor people into
biomatter right which is fine like if we
do it through fascist means or whatever
but like it doesn't seem like you're
allowing us to do it through fascist
means currently like we'll get there
eventually but what we care about is the
deregulation aspect of it
um and and those guys are basically
conflicted amongst themselves there's
like a little bit of infighting I do
think that there's a lot of class
solidarity amongst the Bourgeois so uh
ultimately I think they'll get together
and realize that like they have a common
goal that unites them so but uh in the
process this back and forth is uh funny
to watch and and entertaining
um you know they're [__] freaks Trump
of course gave a speech and feedback
yeah which was of course uh
accompanied by a lovely ad for gold
coins love that Trump speech special
isn't that just so perfect it's great
text Trump to 65532 to get your free
gold coin yes ladies and gentlemen quite
an offer oh yeah here he is uh challenge
the governors of all 50 states
all 50 states to join me in a great
beautification campaign we will rename
our schools and boulevards
not after Communists but after great
American Patriots bro I don't think I've
never been down like Marks Street or
like Lennon Avenue I don't know there's
one privately owned Lenin statue in
Seattle that they like make a big stink
about all the time which like you know
good luck Lenin was pretty [__] cool
so suck my dick but it's it's not every
street now my timer's broken what is
happening today
oh no leftovers out I'm dead anyway
you're back you're back I'm back we have
a lot there's a ghost in the machine
yeah
it's trans people I'm sure technically
this is what this is the 48th episode
right 40th yeah which means one episode
more than what we did with friends yeah
one episode more than you did with
Frenemies which is why like I think the
there's a ghost that's trying to ruin it
and they're like no we're not we're not
letting you we're not letting you film
this episode how dare you we're filming
it God damn it yeah we're trying our
best here
the button is gone chat the button is
gone for this episode because you're
static
um
bad and ugly buildings and return to the
Magnificent classical style of Western
Civilization
dude why is his pore so visible this
man's he has pores on his nose that like
go down to his sphincter like this man
has pot giant holes in his face wait go
back wait can you go back to what he was
saying he's talking about ugly buildings
like what yeah is he anti-brutal
architecture yeah no he's literally one
of the Greek statue guys on Twitter now
wait okay to be fair and I know this is
probably my like most
anti-communist counter-revolutionary
sentiment but like I don't really like
brutalist architecture either I mean
that's fine so uh political talking
point I guess we should let him yeah
they get very uh worked up about
architecture
we will get rid of bad and ugly
buildings and return to the Magnificent
classical style I I don't I don't even
know what what are you pitching like
like I had so many problems in this
country he's like we're gonna get rid of
all the ugly buildings we're gonna tear
them down start all over
so it's a beautiful building this is
wonderful because like when you talk
about like the beautiful classical
Styles in American architecture like
that does not exist in America you
[__] idiot like that's not a thing
there is no coherent City Planning in
this country let alone like uh any kind
of any kind of like zoning restrictions
that that uh pertain to anything other
than like allowing single-family housing
to occur by Design and by uh you know by
making it basically illegal to do
anything else and there is no like uh
there is no coherent aesthetic within uh
American architecture unfortunately I
just like the idea that he's going to be
blowing up buildings I will be
destroying buildings that are ugly but
I'll determine which ones are ugly we
all agree yeah also like his whole vibe
is like ugly as [__] so I don't know I
don't know what his like he's gonna be
the idea of beauty is I'll be the I'll
tell you what's beautiful I'm gonna go
up and down the street with a with a
cartoonish TNT plunger
blowing up buildings
right folks you hear this guy can you
believe it
made the made a building melted cars
folks but he made some good designs
we gotta bring him back
sorry
we will support Baby Boomers that we
will support baby bonuses for a new baby
boom how does that sound what is he
talking about
he's saying we want bonuses for babies
to be born you want the baby boom yeah
no he's like he's talking about the the
birth rate decline which happens to
every developed Nation obviously
um when you when you have a developing
Nation when you have a well-developed
nation as a matter of fact at this
moment is that really anything no
because America has like a lot of
immigration still okay in comparison to
a country like Japan that does not allow
immigration or makes it very difficult
um where they do have a dramatic uh
birth rate decline they need a baby boom
legitimate crisis is a consequence of
that we need bonuses for babies
but anyway so he's uh this is
interesting he says his speech
was packed he said on his uh truth
social CPAC was packed for my speech you
couldn't get into the building special
thanks to the area fire department for
making it work so well but then
as if this this isn't the first time
he's uh lied about a crowd size but here
is during his speech what the [__] bro
is that really what
no you can see him on stage yeah
dude there's like 10 people there yeah
the fire department was thank you for
regulating
the only fire risk I see is all those
Empty Chairs man
that is something yeah that's what I
mean like L plus ratio plus Trump was
washed but also like so is DeSantis so
like there's no real you know there are
no real DeSantis heads in the same way
that there are uh Trump heads out there
bro this is emptier than like open mic
night
yeah this CPAC kind of came out of
nowhere it shocked me I didn't even know
it was happening uh and I thought it was
because it was in Japan turns out
Republicans didn't hear about it either
um apparently I missed the best part of
this video at the end well best is the
governors
that photo that you showed I think is
what but it was empty like the the back
side of the you know the room was like
half empty for sure why does it lie wait
why does it lie it's not as uh it wasn't
as like crazy where's the real photo
then
that's photoshopped I think that might
be photoshopped yeah
I saw some other I saw some video from
this the real one
because that's pretty bad too yeah no no
no it's not good at all that's what I
was well I just want to see the real one
that's what I was referencing but I want
to see the real one we'll look for that
but in the meantime here let's finish
this
wow you men are so lucky I'll tell you
Sarah
you are so lucky man
because we get to get lots of babies
yeah shout out Nick Cannon by the way
the reason why he's saying that is
because he wants
um like
you know white white Americans too we
love our white babies we offering
bonuses for the whiter you are the
higher the bonus yeah
the only reason yeah the only reason why
I like uh you know America doesn't have
the the birth rate crisis that like
Japan has because it has a steady flow
of immigration I'm doing my part I'm
having a third baby that's crazy because
I says it's not enough just to keep it
going at two we need to repopulate three
we're going you know wow funny that's
some major flicks for you that like you
could you could own like 90 of these
like [__] red pill nerds where you're
like dog you have no children like [__]
are you nobody even loves you bro yeah
you don't have a wife you don't have
children shut the [__] up stop chirping
on [__] podcasts like a woman and
instead go find a woman you know they
call me fat but at the same time
guess what's fat
you're my semen load like I did yeah I
took a fat loads in a cup nice then I
tasted it
and I went that's pretty good it tastes
fresh you gotta hit the fresh bro I
don't know why I said that's disgusting
yeah um no I didn't taste my semen but
um
not that I haven't it's just at that
time I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding so you have it you
haven't I've it's just everything's a
joke here folks I felt worthless I felt
ugly I felt gay I felt that no time
that's what you told me but okay well
I'm repopulating what are they Tim pools
out there crying like no you know I
can't get a date I'm repopulating so
who's laughing now exactly you are you
are before kid you are the real Trad you
are the Trad lifestylist those guys are
fake dude bro I love the Catholic Church
like in my adulthood I decided to
convert to the to the religion that is
like most notably known and associated
with pedophilia like listen to my
podcast please meanwhile this
[__] out here having children
dog what are you doing having no
children zero child listen to my life I
go home I spend time with my wife and my
kids I don't even drink I don't do drugs
well maybe that's not trash bad but like
we know together we sit together I'm
having kids who the [__] are you [__]
I'm traditional America I'm the new
America this is the face of America you
are way more conservative of the man
who's repopulating America who the [__]
are you bro yeah you can't even find the
woman to touch your dick let alone to
even brush your shoulder you creep you
filth castrated you're castrated by your
political ideology yeah might as well be
honestly at this point [__]
you're getting none you're getting none
dude absolutely what are you having kids
Brad
I'm not tread I I am a a moral
degenerate like I I ride with that
that's why they hate having kids dude
dude you got plans for kids you want
kids yeah I do want okay good let's get
them out there let's pump them out all
you guys how old were you when you had
your first job
let's see Theodore is gonna be four in
June so how old were you vis-a-vis
crunch some numbers 33. you were 33 God
damn it was 30 when she had her okay I
got I got two years
you know you said something funny that I
didn't comment on you go
oh when when liver King yes you have
kids you said I'm only 31. yeah I was
like no I'm 31. and then I no no but as
soon as I said it I realized like [__]
that's actually it like the time when
people have children big time yeah but
it rolled off the tongue so easy for me
because I think future Generations will
probably also look at that and go yeah
what do you mean he's 31. but right now
we're in the in between phase where like
31 is like kind of the time when you
would have children it is it is because
you're established hopefully you're more
you know
you're more uh
I don't know gives a [__] just have some
kids son don't make me beg
you've have you found someone to have
kids with yet
no no
maybe who knows you so maybe you have
found someone to have kids with no I
just don't I don't I'm not thinking
about it at all you know what I mean are
you single Hassan
why do you always do this to me every
time we're on on this podcast do what
like I don't want to talk about my
private life okay please let's move on
that's all you have to say that's all
you had to say
cut kill the music he's doing it he's
doing this because he wants he wants he
sees all the thirst posts on the h3h3
subreddit and he's like we gotta we
gotta we gotta cut these three
no I just want to know who you are yeah
but clearly you've seen the Hassan Thurs
post on the subreddit I have seen those
on Thursday bro what the [__] I love it
I don't pay that much attention to the
third one hunk of a man yeah tell the
mods no more thirst posts on Hassan only
Ethan thirst post thank you those ones
get like 50 up votes by the way
the Eden they're supposed to do yeah
they don't do great yeah they don't do
that good
yeah I'm married to the game
I have 30. I have like 30 to 40 000 kids
whatever technically
Ethan's hot I don't care what anyone
says and then the comments they're like
yeah he's he's okay he's not that bad
he's not as bad as people say that's my
first post you look good everyone
dieting still have you been keeping up
the diet I've been I've been
steady I'm not gaining weight I'm
getting ready for another oh you're like
I'm doing maintenance guys yeah okay
what's funny about that I mean I don't
know because you were kind of killing it
you were on a tear losing a lot of
weight I'm I'm prepping myself I gained
six pounds in Japan over the course of
six days yeah I ate so many [__] egg
sandwiches oh wait I was gonna ask
because you said you don't eat fish I
don't need fish so what was your but
maybe that photo of me and Connor with
the meats yeah oh I love me the Kobe was
that like uh that was in Kobe oh yeah I
went to Kobe to have Kobe beef it was
one of like his top five meat
experiences top five dining culinary
experiences in my lifetime you know I
had a at a nice restaurant once I had
like a little cube of it of the real
stuff that's the only time you've ever
had it yeah it's because one time the
one time plenty of restaurants in
America that serve A5 like real A5
right I I don't know I mean I I haven't
had it other than than that
mind-boggling like the real [__] though
you were you were so rich and you eat
literally frozen pizza and then you've
only had A5 one time like what's the
reason what's the purpose like wealth is
meaningless if you can't [__] uh
enjoy the experiences the food because
I'm a man of the [__] people how many
times do I have to tell you that yeah
you are such a classic piece of [__] I
am I literally am I ride the train
I take the bus what train I eat [__]
frozen pizzas and I eat discount steaks
Ethan is so rich he has his own train
and I'll have you know Hassan as a man
of the people
that I proudly eat frozen pizzas yeah
and I do I take it even further I treat
myself and sprinkle a little cheese on
top before it goes in the oven yeah
because I'm a man because
cereal in the morning
I love pizza what kind of cereal I don't
even have cable TV wait what kind of
cereal Lucky Charms [__] okay
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is my [__] or
cabin Crunch and I tell you sorry about
Lucky Charms what what's the secret
this is going to blow your mind if you
compare it to all other breakfast
cereals it has the lowest calorie per
cup it will blow your [__] mind it's
140. you look at all the healthy cereals
they're like 200 220 per cup yeah all
that [__] is both [__] charms it's
low calorie when is the last time you
had One Singular cup of cereal though oh
like that's my problem is like talking
about calories but yeah I can't have
like one cup that's my issue that's why
I never have cereal even though I love
cereal yeah cereal is not it's not a
safe meal because it you just go all
over yeah you might be right about the
calories how much sugar does Lucky
Charms have well I mean it's literally
marshmallows in there I'm talking about
calories yeah marshmallows are good
sugar so it's low in calories I mean
that's where all cereal calories come
from they're all packed with sugar bro
yeah yeah okay yeah where else is it
coming from
you know I'm willing to bet they found a
way to just like you know because it has
a lot of marshmallows maybe they just
like put the
they're like here in this one cup of
lucky charm cereal there is no even
distribution of marshmallows there's
like one marshmallow so they're like
it's a 140 calories they're stealing it
they could actually do that that's an
interesting Theory no I mean all of this
stuff all of the food regulation is so
stupid so this country um what did you
eat though before you before you decided
to viciously attack me for being a man
of the people I had a lot of so there's
like a conveni culture there like
convenience stores are incredibly
popular and they are very consistent
good [__] there
7-Eleven is huge there 7-Eleven has his
own bank seven Bank really yeah
7-Eleven
gigantic franchise um so they have
everything pretty much they have
sandwiches they have like cold food that
you can uh warm up right there with them
in a microwave I didn't try those so is
there chefs and back making it and just
putting it in the vending machine no I
think they have like massive facilities
where they make it and then they
distribute it all across Japan but the
consistency is what I'm talking about
like there's so there's Lawson
Lawson's and then there's like a natural
losses which is like one level above
that I guess uh Lawson's is a
convenience store okay uh Family Mart is
another one and then 7-Eleven is the
last one right these are the three main
convenience stores that you can find
everywhere in Japan and they all pretty
much give or take have the exact same
stuff but what would you get out of
there uh exam egg salad sandwich egg
salad sandwich you lift you lived on
that I had like probably six to ten
every day but how good can an egg salad
sandwich be so good
it's it's just egg and mayonnaise it's
so good I don't know how they it's just
they they struck the perfect balance
um so I had a lot of that and then there
was like katsu sandwiches that they also
had that I had like the pork color
sandwiches that I had a lot ham and
cheese sandwiches I had a lot of
sandwiches from convenience stores a lot
of fried chicken from convenience stores
which are also decadent and delicious
it's like weird to think about but like
7-Eleven Fried Chicken is I mean Family
Mart 7-Eleven and losses chicken fried
chicken is incredible Fried Chicken yeah
and so what what was the prices like
what did you find it to be expensive
very cheap incredibly America's so
[__] yeah no in Japan
um the the cost of living
depending on I mean housing is very
expensive regardless because like Tokyo
super dance and a lot of the jobs are
there so there's a massive problem with
that but other than housing
uh food for the most part is super cheap
so how much was one of these egg salad
sandwiches I don't remember I don't know
the exact number but like on the piano
was it do you remember how much you paid
for it and yeah I think it was like two
dollars three dollars wow yeah you could
not get a [__] you couldn't even get
an egg one egg for two dollars here yeah
it's it's it's definitely significantly
cheaper
but of course the average wage is like
lower too in Japan so there's that yeah
but yeah and the meat quality is
incredibly High
yeah it's the end of the day the amount
of I mean I had that I had like a lot of
raw meat I had a lot of raw meat they do
they have like raw beef it's almost like
a flex yeah they even have raw chicken
in certain places I did not try it I did
not try it I'm not brave enough but you
know it's it's mostly like a like a flex
chicken Sashimi yeah no thanks
oh no
but um
there's people stopping and taking
photos with you were you like Like a
Freak no I I think like when I walk down
the street in Los Angeles you know I get
probably the same amount of stairs that
I do in Japan it wasn't like that crazy
I didn't notice it okay that's
interesting I thought I didn't I didn't
feel like I actually loved it because
like
I had less fans there you know what I
mean right because you don't get enough
right right yes you're bombarded
everywhere you go with not bombarded but
like there's always an element of like
uh you know people looking over uh when
I'm in public or people coming up which
I don't mind I love I love my fans like
obviously but
um like when I'm live streaming
it's virtually impossible to do that in
America at this point like without a
fuckload of people coming over
and and trying to take photos whereas in
Japan it was like you know it happened
but not nowhere near to the same
frequency that it does in
um in in the United States that's one of
the reasons PewDiePie moved there is
because people don't know who he is
there that's got to be nice because he
was so famous
yeah I I totally understand why he did
that like I get it I'm I I'm I would do
it too yeah I get recognized when I go
outside it's like crazy you know people
it's crazy I gotta be like yo do you
everybody do you go outside a lot though
think about that like how much how much
time do you know and outside of this
studio and outside of your house in the
train not only frequently ride that's
what I mean well yeah I am in the man of
the people on the bus and the train
happens a lot like if you're constantly
outside if you're constantly when I go
grocery shopping like you know I can
stop two to three times you know what I
mean by people that either work there or
I haven't been in a grocery store in
years
man of the people man of the people I
don't leave my house so I don't leave my
house in fact I I think I've gotten a
measure of almost social anxiety let's
say or I don't know if it's social
anxiety but it's like some kind of
anxiety of being out in the world it's
not exactly agoraphobia either it's just
like I'm so used to
you know not being outside
I feel awkward some like out in the you
know out in public I I understand that
oh you do thanks I understand that I
mean my my interaction in the real world
is also severely limited too
some would you say that it would be
healthy for Ethan to maybe himself take
a trip to Japan I mean he could maybe
take the podcast with him
um you know we could do like a special
out there that would be fine that'd be
good have you ever been anxiety yeah no
that's a good idea Dan I can just do it
I can just do it myself on my phone
you'll need a little bit of help I mean
you always run and Gun you know what I
mean a little bit of Hell recorded
you're not the best you know you are
that is a good idea I'll run and Gun it
through if you go I'll come with you I I
I've yeah well look I've traveled I've
traveled to Western Europe a lot
obviously I grew up in turkey and um
I've been all around Europe for the most
part
and uh
out of every single place I visited I've
never felt like oh dude I want to come
back here immediately I hate traveling
but like interesting with Japan I was
like I need that any excuse what do you
think it was about Japan that appealed
to you so much
um
I don't
I've been literally grappling with this
myself trying to comprehend it but I do
think that um Japan is is
almost contradicting to like everything
I believe and see and experience there's
a lot of issues in Japan that are
brushed aside for the most part
especially if you're visiting as a
tourist for for a little while right you
don't get to see the full thing you
don't get to you know peek uh inside the
curtain right but um it's hyper
capitalist America wrote its
Constitution right there's so many
issues that come from that but because
they have like thousands of years of
rigid structure and tradition and
instilled understandings of of uh
collectivism
uh that is reinforced through a culture
of Shame which can be very damaging
right
um it just kind of makes it work
you know what I mean one example I use
is there's like so many different
railroad companies in Japan right so
there's a lot of complications that
arise as a consequence of that there's
like
uh there are issues you have to like
constantly switch over lines and and all
this stuff right
um going through different uh
municipalities
um however
when you look at a country like America
where there's very little public transit
it doesn't even matter and they somehow
make it work uh and it and that
transition still is relatively seamless
and it's really weird because like if in
America if you had like Amtrak and and
other uh carriers running on similar
lines you'd be [__] constantly
hitting one another like every every
public transport train would be like
literally doing head-on collisions
Non-Stop
um but it works in Japan it works so you
like Japan because it works
yeah I mean I I like it because it's uh
it's a a developed nation that has uh
you don't like undeveloped Nations
I mean there's a I mean I grew up in it
we hate I literally grew up in one so
well I mean I can say and I also
developing nations I well
I I like the
structure of a developed nation that has
like
a a decent amount of wealth but is able
to in comparison to the United States of
America make more work with less okay
okay um that's what it is for me in
particular should we talk about
um I have two other things we can we
don't have a ton of time but hell is all
about the respect we've got the Tucker
got his hands on the January 6 footage
from
um we've also got Dominion lawsuit which
I think is pretty good
how they were able to get all the texts
from them and yeah I love that Discovery
it's really good I'll show you guys the
text Tucker
um we can go through the January 6
footage really quickly if you want like
it's because that's not as long as a uh
there's not as long as a video or
anything like that you could just like
show
this one's actually really easy and I
let's just do this one and then we'll do
that one because okay if we run out of
time
I think this won't be easier it's easy
to set up so Dominion is the voting
system that Trump Fox News and uh you
know uh Newsmax and all these guys were
saying their machines are not safe and
they helped facilitate the rigging of
the election now
Dominion is suing all those people
specifically Fox News for 1.9 billion
dollars in Damages
and defamation lawsuits as I've said on
the show many times are very very hard
because you have to prove essentially
that the person defaming you knew what
they were saying is wrong and you know
many times you just don't have the kind
of evidence to support that kind of uh
of a finite claim
but what's happening with this Dominion
lawsuit is really interesting in the
process of discovery they obtain text
messages
from Tucker they explain they got text
messages from
um
Murdoch Murdoch they got text messages
from uh that other big head guy Hannity
Hannity yeah
all the executives is a star-studded
cast
it's wonderful to see them uh in private
in the way that they discuss these
matters and the disdain that they kind
of have for their audience like they're
completely aware that they are uh you
know they're they're posturing on
television to an audience they're
locking they're knowingly lying yeah
it's so and they know they know how
stupid their their fan base is
uh Alaskan bull worm wants to know why
your haircut makes
your head look normally proportioned oh
hell yeah thank you so much for that
I paid that person yeah is that you that
was you bro yeah that was me I was I was
tweeting it from my phone yeah so here
on Trump's business history
as uh as votes were being counted in
2020 presidential election Mr Carlson
texted one of his producers fighting
about viewers turning away from Fox News
after the network called Arizona for
President Biden the producer said Trump
has a pretty low rate of success in his
business ventures Tucker Carlson
responded that's for sure all of them
fail what he's good at is destroying
things he's the Undisputed world
champion of that Tucker said of trump
continue on on Trump's plan to skip
Biden's inauguration
a staff member texted uh Carl Carlson to
say they'd heard Mr Trump was planning
to not attend the inauguration important
symbol of the peaceful transfer power
Carlson said I'd heard that about the
inauguration hard to believe it's so
destructive it's disgusting I'm trying
to look away he said of trump not going
to Biden's inauguration
yeah it's almost like a normal guy
behind this scene no it's funny because
like that's what I think no he's not
he's not a normal guy uh here's why I
love that because like I unlike yourself
am infinitely more cynical about like uh
the American government and also like
all this symbolic [__] right and what it
means so I don't care ultimately like
I'll I'll talk about how crazy it is and
how funny it is but like deep down
inside I don't really give a [__] right
um but it's funny that Tucker Carlson on
the other hand is like such a uh
civility liberal after all even though
he himself is like a devastating wasp
nationalist who cuts racial adject prop
every [__] night uh in a very
successful way if I may add
um deep down inside he's still like I
can't believe he's not doing the
symbolic stuff though that's you're
undermining the the Integrity of the
American institutions like please if you
could go to his broadcast for that night
I'm pretty sure he'd be like why why
should uh president Trump go to the
inauguration when there's so many
questions about the legitimacy of the
election well he's literally doing that
right now
number three uh on his interaction with
Trump's team over Sydney Powell uh The
Psychotic Trump lawyer
he texted with Fox News Laura Ingram
about Sydney Powell a lawyer for Mr
Trump and one of the biggest promoters
of the election fraud claim Carlson said
I had to try to make the White House
disavow her which they obviously should
have done a long time of course she was
a guest on his show several times Laura
Ingram said no serious lawyer could
believe what they were saying Carlson
says but they said nothing in public
pretty disgusting and now Trump I
learned this morning is sitting back and
letting them loose lose the Senate he
doesn't care I care it's like they're
saying behind the scenes
how much he cares about
doing the right thing but then he goes
on his show and does the opposite of how
he personally feels no no no no no he
doesn't care about doing the right thing
understand this
Tucker Carlson ultimately is a rich guy
yeah right he might have a legitimate
like ideological reasons for why he's
promoting you know fascist uh ideas and
Concepts But ultimately as a rich guy he
cares about just you know maintaining
his wealth and serving the even richer
guys that pay him hundreds of millions
of dollars
so Donald Trump in certain instances
when he does stuff like this when he
undermines the Integrity of the American
institutions is actually presenting a
danger
to the way things are for wealthy people
because if the system collapses entirely
then all of a sudden
the the super rich guys are are not
going to be able to turn profit in the
same way that they are able to right now
it's always better to like not fully
starve out the population and give him
some breadcrumbs to make them feel
comfortable in their existence than it
is to like truly undermine the entire
system let it crumble uh because when
you undermine the entire system and let
it crumble as it stands currently when
there's still problems to be made
um you're going to you're going to give
up on a lot of uh your amenities a lot
of your your but if it he just I guess
you could say more specifically he's
going against his own interest when he
goes on the show
and you know goes with the talking
points but he goes on this is about the
aftermath of the capital riots
after the riots at the Capitol on
January 6 Mr Carlson texts
with Mr Pfeiffer who's the Pfeiffer is
that a producer yeah that's the producer
okay about uh Mr Trump's culpability and
their Insurrection how to deal with
viewers who still support him this was
two weeks before Biden's inauguration
Carlson says Trump has two weeks left
once he's out he'll become incapable
incalculably less powerful even in the
minds of his supporters Carlson
continues he's a demonic force a
destroyer but he's not going to destroy
us I've been thinking about this every
day for four years Pfeiffer says you're
right I don't want to let him destroy me
either the Trump anger spiral is vicious
Carlson says that's for sure it's deadly
it almost consumed to me in November
when Sydney Powell attacked us it was
very difficult to regain emotional
control but I knew I had to we've got
two weeks left we can do this what these
conversations are so ridiculous well
Tucker Carlson I mean shouts out the
Roger Ailes uh Rest in Piss but like uh
you know Fox News as an institution is
was designed uh deliberately to be the
propaganda arm of the Republican Party
in the Republican interest right
so Tucker Carlson having this
conversation uh in private is hilarious
to me because this is the exact same
conversation that is happening in every
uh uh every Circle in the Republican
party because the Party Machine
currently has these two conflicting
forces they have geared up the base to
be more and more extremist right because
the culture war is the only thing that
keeps people going keep people going out
to the polls keeps people going out and
voting because like you're not offering
them any sort of material restitution
you're not offering them anything you're
not offering them health care you're not
offering them like Financial Freedom or
anything like that so how do you make
work the deregulation uh uh narrative
how do you make work the the tax cuts
for the wealthy narrative you shift the
attention away you pump up the American
dream rhetoric and then you shift the
attention away from like the genuine
damaging impacts that this kind of
attitude has this reaganite uh reaganism
attitude has on
on the economy as a whole any focus on
marginal issues culture War issues and
you create this culture War agenda and
you constantly have to you constantly
have to push that button over and over
again and people demand more and more
and more so now you've gotten to a place
where Donald Trump sees all of that and
reads the room very well and is able to
communicate the cultural War narratives
without without the dog whistles really
that's why he's so appealing but when
you do that
um when you when you uh you know rush to
your uh base of support that hard
you will cause instability like Donald
Trump in many respects was a victim of
his own success uh the reason why the
Republican party is currently suffering
electorally is because they cave to the
demands of a uh hyper Vigilant violent
extremist base of support that they have
in the form of uh White uh uh White
Protestants right
um they make up a tiny percentage well
not tiny but uh you know not a large
enough percentage to like win elections
nationally but they capitulated to them
they created the Federalist Society they
set it up uh and designed systems to
specifically concede to their demands
and once they got those demands which
were inherently anti-democratic and the
only way to achieve them was uh going
against the wishes of the majority when
they did that so brazenly all of a
sudden people like what the [__] I'm
conservative but like you know I have a
daughter I and God forbid what if she
needs to get an abortion I'm
conservative but I'm seeing young women
all around the country uh who are not
able to get medical procedures from
their doctors because doctors are afraid
that they're going to go to jail when
they have like when and they're forced
to give like stillbirth uh uh abortion I
mean um when they're forced to give
birth to a stillbirth fetus right yeah
this was my favorite one by the way
uh and I'm wondering if Trump I feel
like has to respond to this he goes on
his desire to move on from Trump Carlson
said Mr Carlson texts with members of
his staff two months after the 2020
election and two days before the
Insurrection at the Capitol building and
looking forward to not having to cover
Mr Trump Carlson said we are very very
close to being able to ignore Trump most
nights I truly can't wait he says he
continues I hate him passionately
Carlson says he hates Trump passionately
and so um I wonder if Trump's going to
respond to that but the what's
interesting about this is that you have
proof hard evidence
of Fox News
uh uh pundits saying exactly the
opposite of what they're saying on the
air and it's interesting that it's
turning out that uh they have a very
compelling case of defamation Dominion
voting so you know
they might actually win they might
actually win that 1.9 billion that'd be
so sick I mean it's hard because like
I don't know how much money Dominion has
but like I know Fox News is like great
lawyers this is an open and shut
defamation case but it's still very
difficult to win those so unless you're
Johnny Depp so they're shopping for
uh judges right now yeah the Fox News
ones they're trying to find like super
conservative judges who are like Fox
News Watchers and stuff trying to find
something it's not gonna be that hard no
it's not it's not going to be that hard
um
Fox Corporation 4 billion cash on hand
God that's awesome dude these
[__] got a bank account with
four billion dollars in it yeah love
that for them yeah we're I mean we got
more here at the leftovers one on pound
we got 20 but like I mean they're broke
boys but I just can't get over again we
always talk about how lucrative the
grift is and I just so happy for them
yeah we were able to make it you know
but going back to the Tucker Carlson
thing like there is a dual interest here
right on the one hand they don't want to
rock the boat too hard but they have to
hammer on the volatility they have to
hammer on the the violent narratives
right
but on the other hand I don't want to
rock the boat too hard because like they
still want to make money they still want
to live in Comfort right
and
and that's the issue that's the reason
why he has to tow this delicate line of
like you know uh immigrants are dirty
and need to be purged from this country
while simultaneously not saying it too
much like not going too with the
election narratives which is why and
this is a decent segue I think back to
the other uh video Tucker Carlson
recently came out with the January 6
footage I do want to tell you we have
about
three minutes before that's fine the
only thing I'm gonna say is this you
want me to pull it Carlson was sent 41
000 hours of footage from Kevin McCarthy
speaker of the house yeah so that they
could comb through 41 000 hours of
footage and Tucker Carlson cherry-picked
threw 41 000 hours of footage
I think like around five minutes of the
January 6 insurrectionist like walking
around peacefully and with the cops like
walking them in and there it is here's
the footage that they showed yeah you
can even play this like b-roll in the
background with no audio yeah go ahead
and for some weird reason
this is like a narrative that works for
a lot of these [__] uh absolute
morons
that like five minutes of footage on a
very public event that we all watched
happened two [__] years ago live on
National Television on my [__] twitch
Channel through probably a million
different [__] angles because there's
so much Cam so many cameras there so
much CCTV footage but also because the
[__] idiots that were doing this [__]
were literally filming themselves doing
it you know what I mean because they
didn't think they would get any
punishments for it they didn't think
what they were doing was wrong but but I
guess turns out like five minutes of uh
of peacefully walking through can make
up for the 41 000 other hours of of them
being violent and and psychotic
um one of the key moments that I uh I
love in this is that uh they talk about
how like the police were basically
guiding them around
and uh I'm like yeah no [__] because you
know cops are [__] they they love the
Hogs it's like Pig on Pig violence uh
ultimately they are one the same
um and that is
precisely the reason why they were
walking them around just like here it is
here's the footage that apparently is a
Smoking Gun why is this a smoking gun we
saw cops take selfies with [__]
literally on January 6 like I was
covering it live I'm confused because
when I see footage
of the cops escorting them into the
chambers of Congress I think that oh
yeah well the police are also as we know
Hogs yeah they're they're also like
fascists racist freaks so I don't
understand how how this footage supports
their narrative I'm confused by it I
think they're implying that like there's
this other underlying con narrative
because they they threw a lot of [__] at
the wall to see what's stuck basically I
do wonder what the [__] are these cops
doing first they said it was antifa
first they said it was antifa but then
they were like but also they shouldn't
go to jail even though they're [__]
antifa apparently right so then that
didn't stick so now they're like oh the
January 6 insurrections are political
prisoners that must be freed now they're
prison abolitionists they read Angela
Davis why are they why are they taking
this guy straight to the chamber and
opening the door for him I think it's
partially because they were scared I
think that's what one of the cops
testified at the at the uh when the
committee uh you know brought him up to
the to the stand she think he was like
afraid of like what these guys might do
because he was walking around with like
a you know with the with the flagpole
but there's like a whole mess and they
are terrified [__] so that doesn't as
soon as they and I can actually there
actually is an explanation for why they
were doing this tell me that the cops
gave is that the defendant challenged
the U.S capital officer to let them pass
ultimately using his bullhorn to rile up
the crown and demand the lawmakers be
brought out
um they entered the chambers the officer
falling behind them until there was
sufficient law enforcement to presence
to clear out the room so yeah the thing
is is they cut off what they show is
this footage there's a ton there's
people because all the cops are outside
trying to stop the crowd there's only a
few inside these people get in they
there's way more of them than there are
cops so they just try and de-escalate
and they're like okay just here I'll
show you around they wait for backup and
then right after all the footage that
Tucker showed a bunch more cops show up
they round everybody up and arrest them
yeah and move them which by the way some
of these guys have zip ties and [__]
yeah like that's also you know they're
not there to be peaceful this shot I was
like well there's like 10 cops here in
Riot so here's the thing well here's the
thing though here's here's what I will
say
the reason why what what they're trying
to say basically is that that cop that
died of seizures like the next day he
was not hurt is what they're trying to
say he died for unrelated causes which I
think it's pretty funny for them to like
do this like you know a cab style uh you
know cop murder is fine when we do it
narrative which is pretty funny
um
but also I think they're trying to imply
that like I'm sure you've heard this
narrative Nancy Pelosi purposely refused
to bring in the National Guard and Nancy
Pelosi is the reason why the capital was
not protected on that day which again
still shows that like these that doesn't
that doesn't eliminate the fact that
like these violent Hogs were behaving in
this violent way you know what I mean
like even if the even if the cops
weren't there like that's insane what
they did was was uh you know completely
illegal and unacceptable
so the part they don't show is that
there's already a bunch of rioters
inside the chamber I'm assuming that's
what the that footage is him walking to
the chamber and yeah he wasn't the first
one in there no so so that makes sense
if there's like a angry mob inside yeah
they're all trickling in I don't know
through broken windows but I also don't
have a hard time believing that some of
the cops were sympathetic to them yes
they were they were taking selfies with
them even they were things over to them
on the day of
to me all it says is that the police
were pathetic to them yes Capital police
is notorious for like beating the [__]
out of uh you know disabled people in
wheelchairs and stuff whenever they you
know uh have the audacity to protest
outside of [__] Nancy Pelosi's office
so these guys aren't exactly Good Guys
either okay so I hate this like
mainstream media Narrative of like our
hero cops were not being sucked off by
the by the conservative movement today
and they were being attacked viciously
but like these guys are pieces of [__]
too okay they're not nice so
the thing I guess there's a movement to
free the January 6th Patriots and I
guess this this is part of that where
they're like they weren't they didn't
even Force they were in they were
escorted so they want set up as a frame
job they went off track three the
January 6 heroes that's crazy yeah so he
should yeah there's a ton of people in
there yeah they're like they were doing
a peaceful prayer like that's what
they're making it seem like yeah brother
they were they were definitely just they
were there for peaceful reasons they
made it seem like it was a it was like a
like a tourist day at the Capitol which
I think is hilarious because again
this level of like reality denial is
unimaginable to me but I I guess like
the American conservative movement is at
this level of cognitive dissonance that
uh that they will genuinely deny what
they saw which is not that surprising
when you consider if you've ever talked
to someone who is a conservative who
went to the [__] capital on January 6
and I know people that have they
literally still say it was peaceful it
was actually peaceful and also it was
antifa I'm like bro you were there like
you were are you antifa there's videos
of them it's weird it's like everybody's
all there
yeah so I I have to leave but I'll just
read this statement from the capitol
police chief he said the the program
conveniently Cherry picks from the
calmer moments of our 41 000 hours of
video to incorrectly portray the violent
assault as more akin to a peaceful
protest he added that Carlson's
commentary fails to provide context
about the chaos and violence that
happened before or during these last
tense moments
all right I gotta go thank you Hassan
nice to have you back
um
God bless uh I know you're not happy
about it but I'm glad you're back
yeah I'm glad to be back
this is great and uh we're just gonna
we're gonna we're gonna take leftovers
to Japan soon it's all good okay
Ethan's gonna pay for it it's gonna be
great we're gonna have a great I'll go
with Ila and just one camera it'll be
great just right I'll operate that
camera no problem no be happy no you
won't it's fine ELO's got it uh she's
she's gonna be busy she's she's gonna be
pregnant she can all right guys thank
you so much we'll be back on Friday
which is tomorrow for after dark peace
and love peace and love thanks for
watching bye bye
[Music]
thank you